Carrusel de las artes
[Música]
María Carolina piña
un gusto saludarles nuevamente tengo el
agrado de presentarles en esta ocasión
nuestro programa Carrusel de las artes
desde el comedor del convento de los
cordeleros en pleno centro de París un
edificio que Data del siglo 16 y que
acoge por estos días la exposición de la
fotógrafa venezolana Fabiola Ferrero que
nació galardonada con el premio carmiñac
de fotoperiodismo Y tenemos cita ya
mismo con ella así que acompañarme
[Música]
Fabiola Ferrero Muchísimas gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros en Carrusel de
las artes y nos recibes en el medio de
tu exposición aquí en París acabas de
ganar como lo decía yo antes el premio
carmiñac de fotoperiodismo el doceavo
premio Y eso te permite presentar este
trabajo que se llama Venezuela de West
Run Drive realizado en Venezuela
estas fotografías hablan de la
desaparición de una clase media en
Venezuela en los últimos años a causa de
la crisis económica y política en
Venezuela háblanos de Cómo nació este
proyecto
nació tratando de ser un estudio sobre
la clase media justamente por el propio
interés de Buscar Memorias de mi
infancia de mi propia infancia Buscar
este relato que que están presente en la
clase media venezolana del país de lo
posible del país del paraíso petrolero y
luego realmente fue evolucionando
realmente no era nada más enfocarme en
un estrato social me di cuenta que no
era del centro de mi interés sino más
bien Buscar los rastros de la promesa de
país que fuimos independientemente de
cuál fuese tu estrato social no todos
estos creo que nos podemos identificar
con algún sentimiento de pérdida en el
país
porque se fue tu familia sea porque tu
empresa tuvo que cerrar sea porque las
empresas que
el barrio que tú conocías ya no es el
que era porque así ha ido modificando de
manera muy muy veloz en los últimos
siete años de crisis no
Entonces digamos que yo quería ir
buscando eso y quería mucho hablar con
también personas de otras generaciones
que me contaran ese país que yo no
conocí y yo quería entender cómo ellos
percibían el país
de los años 70 80 y 90 que yo no pude
conocer y ahora para este para este foto
reportaje estuviste en diferentes zonas
de Venezuela captando con tu cámara ese
cambio esa Venezuela de hoy
contrastandola con esa Venezuela que fue
en algún momento otro país cuéntanos
como construiste construiste este este
proyecto así como una forma de comparar
una Venezuela del pasado con una
Venezuela de hoy quisiera No
necesariamente compararla sino
complementar y entenderlas como parte de
un solo relato Y eso es un terreno un
poco complicado porque yo no quiero
decir que mi país era bueno y ahora es
malo yo quiero que se entienda que hay
que hay grises en la historia pero al
mismo tiempo
quiero reconocer que si hay una pérdida
porque la hay muy fuerte
Empezando por los millones de
venezolanos que ahora los números más
recientes hablan de siete Siete millones
de venezolanos que se van del país eso
ya de por sí es una pérdida muy muy muy
potente entonces para buscar estos
rastros primero hicimos un equipo no fui
yo nada más fuimos cinco periodistas
cinco periodistas más yo cada una en una
distinta ciudad de Venezuela que Laura
Elena Castillo en Caracas María Ramírez
en Bolívar nairo Luis Rodríguez en sucre
María Fernanda Rodríguez en Mérida y
Sheila urdaneta en zulia que eran para
mí las zonas donde podíamos conseguir
cosas más representativas de esa
prosperidad que se alcanzó en algún
momento y que vivió en nuestra memoria
como la promesa del futuro y se ve hoy
en día como muy claramente esa pérdida
que buscábamos esta esa la presencia de
esa memoria con el archivo familiar de
las personas que entrevistamos entonces
la mayor parte del trabajo evidentemente
son fotografías que hicimos durante el
proyecto pero también hay mucho archivo
personal de los propios álbumes
familiares de las personas que
entrevistamos que nos hablaban de Cómo
eran el país que ellos recordaban a
través de sus propias imágenes una parte
de la de la serie es por ejemplo tú lo
decías en el estado zulia del estado
petrolero por excelencia en Venezuela
donde Todavía están los pozos de
pedevesa de la de la petrolera estatal
venezolana y con pobladores que estaban
en algún momento
asociados a esa industria petrolera hay
una hay una foto que a mí me llamó mucho
la atención que ese es una señora mayor
de unas 87 años en su casa vive sola eso
te permitió también entrar en la
intimidad de los pobladores venezolanas
venezolanos hoy y contar lo que es la
vida cotidiana de esas personas hoy Sí
esa señora es auristela Salazar tiene
para ahora debe tener ya 88 años
y ella efectivamente toda su familia
tenía una tradición de trabajo en la
industria del petróleo O sea desde su
abuelo O sea desde los años 20 30 su
familia estaba ligada a la industria
petrolera vivió en carne propia lo que
era la prosperidad petrolera y hoy en
día efectivamente ya vive sola en esta
casa que era de su papá como muchas
personas mayores en el país sufre
digamos los cortes de gas los cortes de
luz a pesar de eso debo decir y lo veo
con ella y lo veo con todo el mundo para
mí son como especies de bastiones de
resistencia ante la destrucción y
abristela y sin duda una de esas
personas ella se cose todavía hoy en día
sus propios vestidos también a modo de
ahorrar pero también porque es parte de
su espíritu entonces
para mí también era importante Resaltar
esa vida diaria O sea que hay sutilezas
hay bellezas hay dignidad que no es un
pueblo que no tiene agencia que no es un
pueblo que no tiene voz ni que no tiene
vida si la tiene y está muy presente de
hecho más presente cuando se resiste con
tanta fuerza una destrucción tan
evidente y otras instituciones Donde ha
habido destrucción y tú lo muestras En
tus fotografías son por ejemplo las
universidades
muestras universidades que ya no existen
que fueron un polo educativo importante
en Venezuela y que ya Sencillamente
están completamente destruidas háblanos
un poco también de esa Venezuela que
descubriste que está fuera de Caracas sí
la universidad de oriente es la que yo
diría que físicamente realmente no
existe porque fue destruida la
infraestructura por completo sin embargo
vuelvo a lo de antes existe porque
existen los profesores que siguen dando
clases aunque no ganen dinero y enseñan
en sus propias casa A eso me refiero con
la dignidad y con el Temple con que se
afronta esto sin romantizarlo y decir
que Ay mira que que bueno es el
venezolano que no le importa lo que pasa
para nada es una aceptación muy solemne
de resignación un poco por lo que nos
rodea no y las universidades no se
quedan atrás o sea las universidades
autónomas del país han tenido unos
cortes de presupuesto muy potentes que
hacen que sea imposible realmente
mantener la infraestructura mantener los
profesores mantener la seguridad de los
de los establecimientos y terminan con
cosas tan extremas como la destrucción
de 100.000 libros en la universidad de
oriente que son años de investigación
que no se pueden recuperar qué me dices
de Caracas también hay fotografías tuyas
en lugares que fueron símbolos de la
capital venezolana por ejemplo está el
complejo que se llamaba Parque Central
que eran unas unos rascacielos
impresionantes en Venezuela que hoy en
día están casi desmantelados realmente
todavía allí pero no son ni la sombra de
lo que fueron en los años 70 por ejemplo
sí Parque Central es sin duda un clásico
ejemplo de la clase media venía menos no
porque es todo este complejo Que Durante
los 70 y 80 era considerado un complejo
urbano importantísimo en América Latina
que tenía cientos departamentos dúplex
para familias y aparte tenía museos
tenían las Torres para oficinas es decir
era una cosa que aspiraba la grandeza y
hoy en día porque central de nuevo la
infraestructura está sufriendo muchísimo
De hecho cuando yo yo fui en los
estacionamientos estaba el segundo piso
estaba completamente inundado o sea
podías nadar dentro porque las tuberías
están rotas y son esas como pequeñas o
no había sensores por ejemplo unos
edificios que tienen no sé 40 pisos no
tienen ascensores tenían uno nada más
disponible entonces son esos pequeños
retos de la vida diaria donde realmente
diferencia las carencias
y creo que un poco el proyecto vacío un
amigo las veía hace poco y me decía
Y esto es un dilema amigo también que yo
siempre me estoy cuestionando si si la
estoy haciendo justicia la gravedad era
gris o sea Cómo consigo ese ese balance
entre no victimizar y decir que mira
esta pobre gente pasando hambre ni
romantizar demasiado decir mira qué
bella es la destrucción o sea cómo
hallar esa ese ese balance no
Y eso es algo que siempre esa pregunta
te la hace siempre que haces una foto no
siempre porque sino no trabajo pero si
cuando por ejemplo cuando edito Sí
porque yo digo esta foto realmente
aporta o es solamente por la estética O
sea que que
cómo hallar ese balance entre no ser
simplemente información pura sin ningún
tipo de sensibilidad y no ser un exceso
de estética que no aporta información
háblanos un poco del circuito que
propones aquí en París porque hay dos
entradas posibles entre la Venezuela del
pasado y la Venezuela en el presente
háblanos un poco de lo que eso que tú
propones al visitante de esta exposición
Yo realmente lo imaginaba como el
presente del pasado coexistiendo
constantemente porque así lo vivo yo
personalmente cuando voy como que todo
el tiempo están las memorias demasiado
presentes a la vez que ves lo que tienes
enfrente no como la casa vacía para mí
es el presente del pasado al mismo
tiempo es la misma casa no es la misma
casa entonces en este caso lo que
quisimos hacer un poco más fácil para la
gente para entenderlo y dividimos el
pasado y el presente Entonces si entras
por la derecha vas a ver el pasado que
son las fotografías tomadas de los de
los álbumes familiares de las personas
que participaron en el proyecto de las
mismas personas que ven fotografiadas
van a tener unos documentales que pueden
ver sobre cómo era la Venezuela de los
años 80 y así pueden entender un poco el
contexto De dónde viene este imaginario
colectivo de la Venezuela rica y posible
y luego pueden entrar al presente que
entonces allí hay sobre todo retratos de
las personas que entrevi y mucho enfoque
realmente en la infraestructura
en la destrucción de la infraestructura
no en la decadencia del paisaje diría
pero que Igual dentro de esos paisajes
entonces dentro de esos retratos se
encuentra el centro del trabajo que es
la búsqueda de la promesa perdida Ya
para terminar esta entrevista me
gustaría que nos hables de tu visión de
la fotografía porque cuando vemos Esta
serie hay apelas mucho a la memoria
quizás utilizadas a la fotografía para
plasmar algo que quizás ya no existe
pero que apela a la memoria a la memoria
de los venezolanos a la memoria de las
personas que vivieron en ese país que tú
decías no conociste en una época Esa es
tu tu visión de la fotografía de tu
oficio sí fotografía o al menos es el
centro por lo menos ahora de mi trabajo
Buscar preservar la memoria Hay ciertos
también problemas con el tema de los
archivos en Venezuela lo mismo que pasan
las universidades una universidad que
fue destruida eso es destrucción de
memoria también entonces Cómo podemos
ayudar a que esto se registre de alguna
manera pero que se registre no solamente
por el mero hecho de tomar una foto sino
que se registre con la comprensión del
contexto que sea realmente entender un
poco de nuestra identidad de quienes
fuimos de Quiénes somos y este momento
de transición que en algún momento
pasará bueno con esta conclusión que tú
misma nos has dado te agradecemos
Fabiola Ferrero por haber estado con
nosotros en Carrusel de las artes
recuerdo que ha sido la premiada de este
año con el galardón con el premio
carmiñac de fotoperiodismo aquí en
Francia Muchísimas gracias gracias
por su sintonía muchísimas gracias y
hasta la próxima
[Música]